et c'est pour ça que même après avoir eu
un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit ce
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
à la une de 1700 personnes ont manifesté
aujourd'hui à un baume sur oise des
chiffres de la gendarmerie dans cette
commune du val d'oise qu'adama traoré a
été interpellée est décédé il ya quatre
ans une marche organisée par le comité
justice pour adama et c'est une première
alternative à l'une des principales
organisations du mouvement pour le
climat et nous verrons que tout s'est
déroulé sans école
la crainte d'une deuxième vague
épidémique en france n'a jamais été
aussi forte c'est le cas en bretagne
dans les autres france et en mayenne où
le port du masque à dans les lieux
publics clos y est obligatoire à partir
de jour d'aujourd'hui de mesures
effectives sur tout le territoire dès
lundi les autorités sanitaires ne
cachent pas leur inquiétude
[Musique]
et puis le mali toujours plongée dans
l'instabilité politique l'opposition
demandent toujours la démission du
président ibrahim boubacar keïta depuis
plusieurs mois elle même la contestation
bilan au moins nous ment selon les
autorités l'onu parle de 14 décès et les
leaders du mouvement 24 la communauté
des états d'afrique de l'ouest appelle à
la formation d'un gouvernement d'union
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france quatre ans
après la mort d'adama traoré lors d'une
interpellation à beaumont-sur-oise des
milliers de personnes ont défilé dans le
calme dans cette même commune du val
d'oise aujourd'hui une marche a co
organisé par le comité justice pour
adama et l'organisation écologique
une première lorenzi et alternatiba on
le rappelle le jeune homme noir âgé de
24 ans est décédé le 19 juillet 2016 peu
après son arrestation au terme d'une
course poursuite avec les gendarmes qui
ont utilisé la technique du placage
ventrale l enquête sur sa mort par
asphyxie et relancer on l'a appris cette
semaine on va faire le point avec notre
reporter kirill que tchekhov qui a suivi
cette marche
plusieurs milliers de personnes étaient
présentes à cette marche à l'appel du
collectif justice pour adama des
associations écologistes et des gilets
jaunes ont également répondu présent
après une conférence de presse sur le
parvis de la mairie de persan en cours
de laquelle la merde adama traoré s'est
notamment exprimée le cortège est parti
de la gare de beaumont-sur-oise il a
traversé la ville pour s'arrêter à
plusieurs points stratégiques c'est
alors que à la porte parole du collectif
assa traoré a fait plusieurs discours
elle s'est également exprimé au micro de
rtl france quatre ans après la mort de
son frère
le combat continue pour faire toute la
lumière sur les causes de son décès à la
justice joue avec le temps c'est pour ça
que récuse et on demande la récusation
de la juge qui instruit dans notre
affaire depuis quatre ans qui emmène le
dossier vers de non-lieu quatre fois
aujourd'hui la vérité elle est là nous
demandons nous avons tous les éléments
pour aller vers un procès public
au micro de rtl france également madjid
messaoudene initiateurs de la marche
contre l'islamophobie qui est revenu
notamment sur les violences policières
et l'impunité dont bénéficient certains
policiers
une impunité selon lui beaucoup trop
fréquentes voire banal on est au niveau
de la gendarmerie où est décédé adama
traoré dans l'indifférence générale
et il est quand même assez évident que
ce sont les gendarmes qui ont laissé
mourir à damas et qui l'ont qui l'ont
qui l'ont tué donc pendant quatre ans
une famille mobiliser des soutiens des
personnalités des collectifs d'autres
victimes qui sont venus dire que ça
suffit
que y'en a marre que les noirs et les
arabes dans les quartiers populaires
meur soit sous les balles de la police
soit suite à une arrestation en
utilisant des techniques conseils
dangereuse type plaquage ventrale
génération à damas génération climat on
veut respirer un message que l'on a pu
lire sur les t-shirts des nombreux
membres du collectif génération climat
qui étaient également présents à cette
marche et pour qui cette convergence des
luttes étaient quelque part à
d'écoulement logique ce contact direct
déjà il ya un petit moment le 16 mars
2010neuf l'année dernière a eu lieu
place de la république le plus grand la
plus grande marche pour le climat qui a
été organisée à paris à plus de cent
mille personnes qui se sont rassemblées
ce jour là c'était aussi la marge et
solidarité et la marche contre les
violences policières et à ce titre à
c'est traoré et ramata dieng sont montés
sur scène pour prendre la parole et
parler aussi des violences policières de
la lutte contre le racisme
et depuis eh bien nos deux mouvements
discute
plusieurs personnalités étaient
également présentes à la marche omar sy
malik bentalha ou encore dj snake et
cette marche finalement a pris fin sur
un terrain de sport spécialement aménagé
pour l'occasion et où les manifestants
ont pu se restaurer et visiter les
stands de plusieurs associations et que
s'est il passé le 19 juillet 2007 des
expertises ont été livrés des témoins
auditionnés pour tendre la justice ne
semble toujours pas savoir ce qui s'est
réellement passé ce jour là on fait le
point en images
[Musique]
où
comment
[Musique]
le
oh
[Musique]
nous estimons que cette expertise n'a
aucune valeur je m'interroge sur le
travail réalisé par ces pseudo experts
ils font honte à la médecine c'est
énième expertise réalisée par des
médecins incompétents la matière
n'apporte absolument rien
[Musique]
l'ong
où
oh
[Musique]
et
on écoute à alexandre langlois
secrétaire général des syndicats vigie
police malheureusement l'époque actuelle
fait souvent ce qu'on retient des
discours de chaque côté et soul on
essaye de ne pas rentrer dans ce clivage
là c'est ben forcément quand il ya
quelqu'un de couleurs qui tue et c'est
en amont crient au racisme qui est
blessé dans une intervention de police
ont cru racisme sans savoir si la
personne est bien d'actes délictuels ou
criminels et même chose nous avons des
syndicats de police de l'autre côté qui
est des corps policiers fait quelque
chose il est forcément innocent parce
qu'il est policier
malheureusement les dents de la
polémique on est dans la surenchère
plutôt que de baser sur des faits et
d'avoir leur rupture il calme pour
analyser chaque situation
bompard rapport parce que la personne
est de couleur ou parce que la personne
et policiers et parce qu'il ya des faits
qu'il faut étudier
il ne faut pas tomber dans l'hystérie
générale à l'heure actuelle
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de chaque
côté malheureusement qui sont pas du
côté de l'apaisement
donc ce serait bien comme l'autre jour
il ya un champion de boxe thaï qui a
fait cette analyse également nous
saluons parce que ça permet
effectivement d'aller dans le bon sens
du dialogue et de se baser à chaque fois
sur chaque situation qui est différente
sur déchets par rapport à la loi
française jean castex en première ligne
encore et toujours même à nantes
aujourd'hui secoué par alain 110 de sa
cathédrale gothique
cela rappelle bien sûr le drame de notre
dame le premier ministre qui s'est
déplacé avec deux ministres l'intérieur
avec un gérald darmanin et la culture
avec roselyne bachelot
visite express selon les pompiers les
dégâts se concentre sur le grand orgue
presque détruit et une enquête pour
incendie volontaire a été ouverte c'est
ce qu'a annoncé le procureur de la
république de nantes
ce dernier a déclaré qu'il n'y avait pas
de trace d'effraction
on va l'écouter avec la maire de la
ville également écouter il y a
effectivement trois départs de feu ça je
peux vous confirmer j'ai vu de mes yeux
à l'intérieur de la cathédrale
monsieur le procureur s'est exprimée
heures en disant qu'une enquête allait
être ouverte je crois qu'il est
objectivement trop tôt pour en tirer des
conclusions pour avoir échangé avec les
équipes qui sont sur place elles font
remonter un certain nombre d' analyses
diverses qui est essentiel c'est que
l'enquêté soit lancé très vite que toute
la lumière soit faite mais il est trop
tôt pour ordonner
évidemment
ce qui domine c'est l'émotion ce qui
domine c'est la tristesse parce que ce
lieu il n'est pas simplement important
est emblématique pour les catholiques
nantais il est important pour tous les
nantais y fait partie de notre histoire
il ya un lien très très affectif bon
c'est un événement dramatique pour la
vie des nantais parce que la cathédrale
est un bâtiment emblématique d'autant
qu'elle avait déjà brûlé dans les années
70 qui avait déjà fortement choqué la
population
mais bon il n'y a pas si vous voulez au
niveau des dégâts il ya des dégâts
importants au niveau du grand port au
premier étage puisque
au grand port vers quasiment disparu à
la crainte d'une seconde vague de
l'épidémie
dès lundi la mesure va entrer en vigueur
partout dans l'hexagone le port du
masque obligatoire dans les lieux
publics clos
c'est déjà le cas à partir d'aujourd'hui
en mayenne en tout cas six cent
cinquante mille masques ont été livrés à
la préfecture par le ministère de
l'intérieur la mayenne qui le plaçait
depuis mercredi en vulnérabilités élevé
après une résurgence du virus à le
département compte à ce jour sept foyers
de contagion un plan de dépistage de la
population a été lancé qui concerne près
de 300000 personnes et le préfet lui a
rappelé le respect scrupuleux des gestes
barrières en bretagne aussi on surveille
de près la situation à là bas le taux de
reproduction du virus est le plus élevé
de tout le territoire le masque a été
obligatoire dès ce matin par ailleurs
dans plusieurs marchés dans le finistère
et puis la situation elle est délicate
également en nouvelles aquitaine le
virus qui continuent de circuler sur le
territoire national mais corisco bout
une deuxième vague 1re confie de monde
en a parlé avec un eric comme chef du
service des maladies infectieuses à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris
il faut savoir que ce genre de virus a
une grande capacité unique à sion
néanmoins il est un peu trop tôt pour
dire si la symptomatologie différent de
ce qu'on a vu lors de la précédente lors
de la première vague en tout cas ce qui
est clair c'est pour beaucoup d'entre
nous les signes que l'on observe chez
les malades nous rappelle énormément les
signes que l'on voyait en février
justement avant que la grosse vague nous
submerge
on espère que que les leçons de la
première vague auront été tirées et
qu'on sera capable de faire face en même
temps on ne peut pas résoudre déficit de
lit un déficit d'hôpitaux un déficit de
personnel non médical de personnel
médical comme ça du jour au lendemain
en plus on est en pleine saison estivale
dont il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
sont partir en vacances et donc
à l'écouter on espère que l'amplitude de
la vague ne sera pas très importante et
qu'on aura qu'on arrivera là géré
correctement le monde de la nuit en émoi
si les bars et les restaurants ont
ouvert ce n'est toujours pas le cas des
boîtes de nuit vous le savez une
situation désastreuse pour ce secteur au
point que ses représentants exhorte le
ministre de l'économie a lancé un plan
de sauvetage
certains d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs
rencontré le ministre délégué aux
petites et moyennes entreprises pour
trouver une solution a le secteur du
monde de la nuit demande à bercy une
prise en charge totale de ses charges
fixes
on va écouter justement à ce propos
patrick malvaes les présidents du
syndicat national des discothèques
selon lui les boîtes de nuits resteront
fermés jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'est pas
question pour les discothèques
d'échapper à la patte de santé
elles sont prêtes à vraiment pas obéir à
cet impératif national et si elles
doivent rester fermés jusqu'en janvier
seront fermées sur janvier est par
contre il faut qu'elles soient prises
financièrement en charge et il faut que
l'on ne tolère pas que d'autres puissent
faire discothèque alors qu elles elles
peuvent pas le faire qu'est ce à quoi on
assiste actuellement pas de discothèque
c'est très facile au jour d'aujourd'hui
il suffit de n'être pas une discothèque
et où les discothèques
vous le voyez dans les rues vous voyez
les barreaux boyer dans les maisons vous
voyez là les locations et à bienne be
partout ce sont les discothèques et le
risque est accru
demain il va y avoir une deuxième vague
qui sera due à ces débordements que l'on
ne contiennent pas que l'on ne combat
pas et cette deuxième vague desquels
vont être des produits soupçonnait ça va
être les patrons de discothèques
parce que eux ni seront pourriez
puisqu'ils sont fermés et eux vont pas
pouvoir retrouver au mois de septembre
donc se trouver lui reste encore différé
ça va être une double peine de l'onb
avoir à les ministres à décines ans et
chefs des banques centrales à des pays
du g20 ont commencé aujourd'hui une
réunion virtuelle sur la reprise de
l'économie mondiale et à l'issue des
discussions
bruno le maire le ministre français de
l'économie et des finances indique que
le g20 est en bonne voie pour obtenir un
accord sur la prolongation en 2021 du
moratoire du service de la dette pour
les pays les plus pauvres c'est un
processus que je soutiens la france le
tout dans un contexte de pandémie liée
aux coronavirus qui continue de frapper
un peu partout les ong elles mettent en
garde le g20 a présidé cette année par
allart
saoudite contre la menace d'une crise de
la dette dans ces pays les plus pauvres
justement et puis les dirigeants de
l'union européenne tente également de
parvenir à un accord pour relancer leur
économie toujours des négociations
autour d'un plan de relance un plan de
750 milliards d'euros qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité hier déjà les membres de
l'union européenne à n'ont pas réussi à
s'accorder après l'échec du dernier
rendez vous en février
alors c'est la position des pays bas de
l'autriche du danemark et de la suède
qui bloque les combes tout compromis de
nouvelles propositions sont attendues
aujourd'hui sien on en parle tout de
suite avec henri sterdyniak chercheur
affilié à l'eau à ses membres à des
économistes atterrés
bonsoir en avouant henri sterdyniak
alors on attend des annonces
ça fait quand même plusieurs semaines
qu'on attend que l'union européenne
s'accordent à cordes en tout cas que
tous ses membres accordent leurs violons
sur ce plan de relance aujourd'hui et
justement il ya des discussions qu
faut-il en attendre
normalement c'est le jour où elle audrey
à bout d'ici peu si on veut que le plan
de relance when your place de matmour
suffisamment ramier le problème c'est
dans l'union européenne 27 nuit que des
il en a quatre ils sont traités il parmi
les dates y en a inquiété du ces les
pays-bas dongle comme il faut
l'unanimité il ya un blog cage alors
justement on va rappeler justement ce
qui divise les états frugaux d'un côté
il ya les pays-bas la suède le danemark
l'autriche
et puis de l'autre côté la france ou
l'allemagne
oui c'est à dire que la france et
l'allemagne et surtout l'italie et
l'espagne sont d'accord pour un vaste
plan de relance de 750 milliards dhs 500
milliards seraient des dons de l'union
européenne aux pays en difficulté et 250
milliards seraient est prêt le problème
c'est que les pays hugo refus
capa dont et donc souhaite qu'il ya
uniquement des prêts que avec des prêts
l'italie et l'espagne serait de plus en
plus endettés et par ailleurs les pays
bas veulent que toutes les décisions de
d'être mis en difficulté soit adoptée
par les à l'unanimité donc que les pays
bas est en quelque sorte un droit de
veto et demandent en échange de ce plan
daide les pays s'engagent à des réformes
structurelles en particulier de leur
système de retraite
oui de leurs systèmes de droit du
travail et bien sûr difficilement
acceptable pour les pays aidés
donc on a un blocage il est lié au fait
que les décisions doivent être prises à
lunel août qu'au révèle justement ces
blocages sur l'état aujourd'hui de
l'union européenne à l'union européenne
ces 27 pays avec chacun ses taux
d'intérêt c'est sa vision des choses et
la solidarité a du mal à se mettre en
place un l'un des prix qui sont très
frappé par la pandémie comme l'italie
comme l'espagne des pays bas est très
frappant à venir en la crise des
migrants comme la grèce l'italie
l'espagne l'un des pays qui sont moins
par ap mais qui veulent pas l'aider est
actuellement berne entrant dans des
discussions de marchands de tapis
est-ce que ce matin il était question
d'accorder à rabais aux 4 go pour qu'ils
acceptent le plan c'est à dire que on
accepterait une paye proft que me remue
cours le budget européen ce qui serait
tout à fait tout à fait bizarre
et dans ce pareil pour d'autres pays les
pays de l'est acceptent le plan à
condition d'être aidés alors qu'eux
mêmes sont très peu frappé par la
pandémie
et donc c'est très difficile d'arriver à
un accord à 27 6 les pays non pas un peu
le sens de la solidarité et aussi faut
dire le
ans de leur intérêt parce que
l'allemagne a bien compris que c est le
grand bénéficiaire de l'union européenne
puisque ça me permet de faire des gains
de compétitivité important et les pays
bas devraient le comprendre aussi parce
que grâce à l'union européenne c'est
quand même un port un centre de passage
extrêmement important dans l'unique dont
les pays bas profitent énormément de la
construction européenne merci beaucoup à
vous henri sterdyniak d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur affilié à la ftq
membres des économistes atterrés
merci à vous la contestation elle
continue oumali la communauté économique
des états de l'afrique de l'ouest
prônant un gouvernement d'union
nationale
ah mais l'opposition ne lâche rien elle
réclame toujours la démission du
président ibrahim boubacar keïta
elle mène une contestation maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois marqué par deux
jours de violences il ya une semaine est
les autorités par le onze morts
l'opposition 24 et hier à un hommage a
été rendu aux victimes elles et
précision c'est avec elle à match est ce
vendredi de manifestations à l'appel du
mouvement dit du 5 juin était annoncé
comme étant à haut risque pour éviter
une nouvelle effusion de sang
cette alliance hétérogène de chefs
religieux de personnalités politiques et
de membres de la société civile s'est
ravisé mercredi les groupes d'opposition
ont préféré organiser une journée de
prière et de recueillement hommage rendu
aux victimes des dernières
manifestations
un changement de cap au moment où une
mission de la cédéao tente de faire
retomber la tension mali elle la
communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest a envoyé une équipe
à bamako pour rencontrer des acteurs de
la crise une mission conduite par l'ex
président du nigeria goodluck johnatan
avec la bonne coopération des personnes
éclairées du mali qui veulent résoudre
le problème
pas pour des intérêts personnels mais
pour l'intérêt général du pays
je pense que nous arrivons à résoudre
les problèmes oui ce sont des problèmes
créés par les humains pas des problèmes
sur lesquels nous n'avons pas de
contrôle
donc je pense qu'on arrivera à quelque
chose vous travaillerez avec nous et
nous y arriverons nous à coutances
optimisme du côté de la cedeao
mais le mouvement du 5 juin ne croit pas
en cette médiation et appelle une
nouvelle fois au départ du pouvoir
malien ibrahim boubacar keïta en fait
d'un point de vue la question à la
connaît le peuple aura le problème y a
pas de problème le peuple ne veut plus
de ce régime régime devient régime qui a
du sang sur les mains
alors venez nous parler vraiment nous
vous dois parti ne doit pas partir et
d'aller vers moi je pense que vraiment
pour moi c'est insultant
l'abside elle ne proposera rien la cdac
compte en tout seulement de sauver des
chefs d'état c'est tout un pessimisme
affiché face en président qui ne
quittera pas le pouvoir puisqu'il élu
démocratiquement
selon le premier ministre soumeylou
boubèye maïga iv cas a tout de même
tenté plusieurs ouvertures y compris
celle d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale son succès cette situation
très tendue inquiète jusqu'à l'onu pour
les nations unies qui appelle à la
retenue les réseaux sociaux jouent un
rôle majeur dans cette escalade dont
l'issue demeure imprévisible
nous avons des informations selon
lesquelles les réseaux sociaux ont été
partiellement bloqué cet inquiétant car
il est important que la population est
accès à l'information
mais dans le même temps il y a des
inquiétudes sur les nombreuses fêtes
news propagée par les réseaux les
messages en ligne qui incitent à la
violence
la médiation diplomatique pourrait durer
au mali pays plongé dans la crise est
confronté aux violences de toutes sortes
des problèmes d'insécurité mais aussi
structurelles la pauvreté y est extrême
et affecte 40 % de la population quant
aux infrastructures routes et hôpitaux
en tête elles tardent à se développer
c'est dans la foulée des législatives du
printemps dernier que la contestation
avait pris son envol des élections
maintenu malgré le coronavirus et
l'enlèvement d'un des leaders de
l'opposition
soumaïla cissé qui est toujours en
captivité des contestataires déterminé à
pousser le président et bekar au départ
selon sadio mort à compter les
journalistes un spécialiste de l'afrique
je vous propose de l'écouter on connaît
ce peuple qui depuis les indépendances a
fait partir à l'exception d'un seul
président alpha oumar konaré à faire
partir tous ces présidents soit par un
coup d'état ou les mouvements de rue
donc je pense que ça va permettre de
faire baisser un peu la tension et de
reprendre les négociations peut-être
même reprise de négociations la reprise
des négociations et pour les
contestataires nous sommes liés au
départ maintenant de ib câble à ibrahim
boubacar keita parce que euh euh euh
veulent que ib cas et des pouvoirs
réduits alors que ib cave conserver la
plénitude de son pouvoir et mettre en
place un gouvernement d'union de la
chaudanne qui l'intéressent pas les
contestataires
allez on va rester sur le continent
africain avec un ce barrage de la
renaissance sur le nil qui suscite de
vives tensions entre l'ethiopie et
l'egypte et le soudan l'on joue le
partage de milliards de mètres cubes
d'eau du plus long fleuve au monde après
l'amazone à un projet hydroélectrique de
5 milliards de dollars qui peinait à
trouver un accord les explications c'est
avec claire nekoé dinars aussi c'est sur
les bords du nil que la civilisation
égyptienne s'est enrichie pendant des
milliers d'années
mais depuis 2011 et le début de la
construction du barrage de la
renaissance en ethiopie l'egypte craint
pour son économie notamment agricoles en
effet le caire redoutent qu'un
remplissage trop rapide du réservoir ne
réduise le débit du feu
un remplissage qui vient tout juste de
débuter l'ethiopie a commencé en plein
printemps arabe et sans consultation la
construction de la plus grande centrale
hydroélectrique d'afrique sur le nil
bleu il s'agit du plus important
affluent du nil qui lui donne 85% de son
no la centrale vise notamment à
alimenter 70 millions d'éthiopiens en
électricité mais à sa construction
l'impact sur les pays en aval du barrage
et qui partage le fleuve soudan et
l'egypte n'avait pas été évalué
le barrage est donc vu comme une menace
pour la souveraineté de l'egypte en
raison d'une population en croissance
constante
le nuit prédit des pénuries d'eau d'ici
à 2025 de quoi rendre très nerveuse
les autorités du caire le soudan lui
voit la situation comme une bénédiction
puisque un niveau d'eau réguliers
devraient permettre d'y veiller
davantage ces terres arides et d'éviter
des inondations et par conséquent de
développer son agriculture
aucun accord n'a encore été trouvé entre
les trois pays
une dispute diplomatique qui à terme
pourrait bien se transformer en une
véritable guerre de l'eau et c'est la
fin de ce journal merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver en
direct dans 30 minutes excellente soirée
à vous sur arte france
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre
et à d'autres experts qui contestent
leur musique six personnes
non non c'est pas vrai il ya des climats
tout c'est maintenant et non ce n'est
pas il y en a pas il ya des gens qui ne
sont pas des chercheurs qui parlent que
la presse met en avant parce que il faut
que du débat il ya plus de débat
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va vers un